what's going on everybody it's warren
and i just watched
black widow after all of this time of it
being pushed back
the release date changing over and over
again it is finally
here thank you so much to marvel and
disney for letting me pre-screen this
and this hit me kind of
it was like a deeper movie for me
because and i guess i should say spoiler
alert if you haven't seen avengers end
game
go see it but spoilers she dies we know
she dies and it's kind of not hard to
watch the movie but sad to watch this
movie because you're like i love this
but
you die and it's sad and but if you get
past that
the movie really is pretty great there's
a lot that i
wanted from this movie in regards to
natasha you know after
end game you want a lot from this movie
you want a lot from
the solo film that we were supposed to
get forever ago and marvel finally did
it they made a movie about black widow a
little bit about her past
and it's great it's a great movie i
loved it they finally told us a little
bit about her past and
i guess my initial reaction is i i want
more
and i'm sad that we can't get more i
mean i guess it's the mcu right
anything's really possible and i think
it was director john watts who recently
said
nobody really dies in this universe
especially with the multiverse coming
and everything but
i think black widow's done i think it's
safe to say that and that makes me sad
because i would love
another black widow film i would love
another movie
that's like this movie i really enjoyed
watching an
entire movie about black widow i really
enjoyed learning about
her past i really enjoyed the story as a
whole it was a very
very well written story it definitely
has some emotion in it as you could
probably guess so there's some
dark parts but there are also some very
very hilarious parts and
kind of sucks that i can't really say
too much about it this is not my
review this is just an initial reaction
i think the review embargo lives in
about a week and that's when i'll give
my
non-spoiler review so i literally just
watched it this is kind of like
right off the cuff i just watched it ran
right up to my studio to record a
reaction
and yeah i mean it was great the action
scenes
it's really nice to see action scenes
that aren't just like a ton of cgi
especially for me i really love like
hand-to-hand combat fighting scenes
with like actual people doing them like
stunt doubles everything like that
that's really cool to see in this movie
i i very very much enjoyed that about
black widow
it almost felt like a spy movie i mean
it is a spy movie it's black widow she's
like
the spy but it was almost like a mission
impossible movie inside of the mcu
which i actually really liked i i really
dig that um it was a really really cool
vibe i wish it were longer there's
there's so much story to black widow i
feel like there's more they could have
told us but i mean in a movie that's you
know
already over two hours long there's only
so much you can do that
there's only so like long you can make a
movie right you can only make a movie
so long so i think it was a good length
i i think they did the best with the
time
that they had but i guess i could just
always see more black widow
okay elena bulova florence um
loved her so much and didn't think i
would
um nothing against her i don't dislike
her by any means and i think the actress
is great
but going into this i didn't really have
any opinion on her i didn't expect to
love her as much as i did she actually
kind of
made the movie for me was it bigger and
better than avengers end game
no let's be honest nothing really is
going to be not at least you know for a
very very long time but was it a great
movie
about black widow yes absolutely i loved
watching it and i can't wait till
everybody else
watches it as well so again can't say
much my review is going to come out when
the next embargo lifts for the review i
think that's in about a week the press
conference is in a couple of days so
i'll share everything i learned in the
press conference about black widow
during that time as well and in the
meantime let me know how excited you are
about black widow in the comments down
below it's
finally here it's not getting pushed
back again fingers crossed who knows
but uh thank you all so much for
watching as always thank you so much for
supporting the channel i will catch you
guys next time
woof